the most viral part of the good doctor I
am a surgeon feels weird saying viral
cuz it has nothing to do with the virus
but let's watch these episodes let's get
started hello Dr
Han you take the bus too no Sean I just
wanted to talk to you that's one thick
scarf it looks borderline uncomfortable
I spoke to the residency director of
pathology and we both agree you'll be a
great fit there are they trying to get
him away from going into the surgical
field and instead go into pathology I
mean there's value in that because
there's less patient interaction but I
feel like his skills in Reading human
behavior okay maybe he is better as a
pathologist I'm a surgical resident as a
pathology resident you'll Touch cases
and lives across all the medical
departments it's an opportunity for you
to help patients without having to deal
with patients he could also have a
really good place in Interventional
Radiology known as IR where there are
procedures performed so you still have
some patient interaction it's slightly
surgical something to consider Sean I am
a surgical resident you
were and you're going to do great work
in pathology people switch residencies
all the time and actually from surgery
is a very common swap to other fields
because surgery is unique it's demanding
and it doesn't mean that those people
aren't good doctors or they failed it's
about finding the specialty that's right
for you lifestyle wise skill-wise
passion wise and initially when you
start many people have the wrong
impression of what the field will
ultimately be like through the generous
support of St Bonaventure Foundation
we've been able to transport Kenny and
his mother from their home in
Mississippi we appreciate you allowing
us to share your case as an educational
opportunity for our St the neurofibroma
started as a small bump near the base of
the spine so neurofibroma is usually a
non-cancerous tumor meaning that it's
not malignant it's benign and the only
time we really intervene with them is if
they start causing symptoms due to their
size or
position wow okay that's a very big size
I'm curious to know if that's ever even
been recorded I mean that's like the
size of a human and it it's almost the
shape of a liver which is kind of
interesting it encircled his abdomen and
grew to over 100 lb but why did it grow
to this size why didn't anyone act on it
blood supply becoming so intertwined
with the patients it was deemed
inoperable but we've been able to come
up with an Innovative surgical plan that
will allow us to slowly peel the tumor
off the front and back of his torso in
one piece and give Kenny his life back
now there are conditions called
neurofibromatosis type one where people
can actually through a genetic mutation
with some of their protein genes
actually have a bunch of different
neurofibromas throughout their body but
I don't know that they have one that can
become that big I think it's more of a a
quantity versus a size I am going to
need 60 units of type B positive packed
red blood cells H for o 60 you operating
on a hemophiliac elephant our patient
has a 200 lb
neurofibroma cool there's more blood in
the tumor than the patient so we're
going to have to follow massive
transfusion protocol those are the
different types of neur fibromas by the
way that we're popping up there's like
spinal there's muscular there's dermal
dermal seems to be the more common type
that's obviously not dermal I could do
some research on Cell Salvage techniques
cancer is a risk but if
we Mendes has put together a pretty big
team so we have everything we need I
feel bad for sea but to some degree
she's right because when you have too
many cooks in the kitchen things get
complicated mistakes get made too many
people mixing around no one knows who's
in charge very very messy situation can
arise Shawn is being punished for
mistakes that Han thinks he might make
in the future he's not punishing him he
just saved his ass okay Kenny the MRA is
going to help us map the blood supply to
the tumor MRA is basically a form of MRI
that's looking at blood flow through the
Dy put into the arterial system the
blood vessels you'll be able to see
where that blood goes and where it's
distributed and where you can make safe
incisions in we should take a stand
meaning what stage a walk out how much
do one of these bad boys cost anyway
about 3 million but it's worthless
unless you stop talking yeah when you
talk or move during an MRI you develop
something known as motion artifact on
the scan where because there's a little
bit of a delay in between each image you
could actually see blurring and it
becomes very difficult to make out what
you're looking at and mistakes could be
made it's not good that works for Jeff
Bezos and Bill bich I'm not talking
about your leadership lecture I'm
talking about this it's such an
extravagant image I've never seen
anything like that we expected the tumor
to grow since the last scans but not to
this extent blood vessels that I thought
we'd be able to quickly cauterize are
now thicker than my thumb thick blood
vessels are problematic because as soon
as you make an incision to cut out the
tumor you get massive bleeding and
because this tumor create a lot of
neovascularization where it literally
released these factors called
endothelial growth factors it created
its own blood supply fat tumors they all
behave in this very unique way where
they actually start sucking life from
you that is why many of our patients who
are advanced in their cancer staging
actually look CTIC where they look so
skinny and worn down really the cancer
starts taking away the calories it
starts using the calories for its own
growth it redirects blood towards the
tumors it's impossible to remove the
tumor without causing you to bleed to
death no I don't care how risk you it is
but then if it continues to grow he's
also going to die you have to make a
decision here Kenny as long as your
heart remains healthy you basically will
be too whoa how can you make that
prediction if this thing starts growing
and it's growing at the speed where he's
like in just a few days the blood
vessels became thicker than my thumb
what's going to happen in a matter of
years in five years this thing could be
three times the size of any other human
at which point he will start suffering
those ill effects want to be
treated
I want to be cured I want my life back I
always thought all I had to do was get
enough money or find the right
doctors but if you're telling me there's
no hope I've never seen in a hospital
where a patient has to cry and advocate
so hard for their case that it will then
change the doctor's mind like it feels
like the medical necessity should change
the doctor's mind not whether or not the
patient becomes emotional she's always
trying to one up us Morgan she's not
staying late because she wants to
research she's staying late so that Han
can see she's staying late that's just
who she is don't take it personal and my
dad's a Taekwondo grandmas coached Me
growing up he always used to say only
you can beat you I did Taekwondo for8
years certainly other people could have
beat me besides me but you know I tried
You' think if you're selling Boba you'd
have straws wide enough to get the balls
throughou them I can't believe you drink
that stuff it's like putting gummy bears
in a
drink is she going to try and clot the
blood vessels I got an idea if we
embolize the larger blood vessels to the
tumor before surgery we can I just don't
understand why they didn't think about
this before why is she having to Bob a
brainstorm here I'm not a surgeon and
yet I figured this out this should
reduce hemorrhaging during surgery and
allow us to excise the tumor without you
bleeding out I also don't understand why
they can't embolize the tumor if they're
embolizing and destroying the blood
vessels to the tumor that can actually
cause the tumor to necrose at which
point it would start getting smaller and
fade and then you could operate on it I
don't understand why you have to do it
in this order just need to get a few
more branches off the aort and we're
done well done Dr Brown this feels like
it's the easiest decision to have made
why did Dr Brown like every other doctor
should be ashamed of themselves what's
his estimated blood loss about 8 and 1
12 lers well that's a lot there's only
like four to five in a human the entire
human body typically only has 5 1/2 L of
blood thanks Sean for factchecking me in
real time let's get 30 more units on
prpc he's like you said four to 5 it's
actually 5 to six
add cryo fresh frozen plasma and
platelets to
that so the unique thing is you see
those pads we frequently use those for
dabbing and getting control of bleeders
but we count those very meticulously
when we bring them out and then when we
put them back there have been many
instances of them being left inside
patients he's crashing he's ventilating
fine we've got no immediate blood loss
or hemorrhaging it looks like
distributive shock I need satat labs and
initiate shock resuscitation for some
reason he's having fluid go into
different spaces throughout his body
causing a low blood pressure but if you
give more fluids essentially you create
more Demand on his heart uh more fluid
entering his lungs and creating a bigger
problem he's got a high white count and
what looks to be a systemic
pro-inflammatory cyto release putting
off the blood supply to the tumors is
causing post imization syndome
interarterial lidocaine 130 Mig of methy
predonisolone start antibiotics should
we be trying to reverse the embolization
restore blood flow to the tumor so this
is uh kind of similar what happens when
a patient loses circulation to let's say
an injured limb if after a while the
body part starts dying and then you
reperfuse the dying portion the body
comes in you get massive inflammatory
response you get massive electrolyte
imbalances and it can actually kill the
person when you remove the thing that's
crushing them so reperfusing a dead or
damaged organ can actually be quite
problematic and this is essentially
what's happening with this tumor right
now page Dr Murphy no do not paage Dr
Murphy I get it you like him but we
don't have time for an audition I'm
trying to save my patient's life my
patient which means it's my call I am
also trying to save your patient's life
so I'm urging you to stop wasting time
now we've cut away almost half that's
all we can do right now so let's remove
it and give him a chance to live and
fight another day why can't you do both
you can walk and chew gum at the same
time can't you surgeons call Sean and
continue on with the procedure if you
clamp the aorta it could lower the blood
flow to the tumor enough to slow the
release of the cyto Kines clamping the
aorta will kill the intestines kidneys
and legs maybe you could do a bypass not
if we release the clamp every 10 minutes
give it just enough blood to stop the
cyto kindes but not so much that he
bleeds to death oh I don't know this
this sounds
awful remember when you're clamping off
the aorta you're also clamping off all
the blood flow to the lower portion of
the body which includes vital organs
thank you for the consult Dr Murphy I
don't know if that's good advice care to
do the honors
let's take it
up they made this procedure I mean it's
complicated granted all the intricacies
of the size of the tumor the blood flow
but they made it sound way more
complicated than it actually was it's a
tumor you clamp off the arteries you cut
them you move on with your life like I
don't understand what the issue is here
you're still going to need some skin and
soft tissue grafts but the Heart part
done your prognosis is excellent thank
y'all so much am I taking this thing
home in a glass bottle y'all got
something that big he's just being a
smartass I'm surprised he's that lucid
after a surgery usually uh patients are
really groggy especially after that huge
amount of blood loss I am not leaving
your office until you reinstate me what
are you doing Sean do you think ordering
me to do something will change my mind I
am a surgeon and the viral meme was Bor
I am a
surgeon I am a
surgeon I am I am a surgeon I am a
surgeon Dr H I am a
surgeon I am a
surgeon I am
a
you are
[Applause]
the you know part of reading social cues
which is something those who are
diagnosed with autism struggle with at
times is um inability to read contextual
cues which often times actually help us
learn to manage our emotions better
that's why a lot of times children who
are diagnosed late or not diagnosed with
the correct condition can actually
develop behavioral issues because they
don't have the checks and balances that
their classmates or peers might have
because they are able to read contextual
cues they are able to use social
guidance to keep ourselves in check
that's not to say what others think
about us is always right but we as
humans have evolved to think alongside
the group to use group ideology to use
others actions to guide our own and when
you're not able to read social cues that
makes the process a lot more difficult
especially when dealing with difficult
moments like traumatic ones maybe even
as traumatic as this Dr Murphy may not
communicate like you do he may not
communicate like I do but make no
mistake he does
communicate and he inspires but I didn't
fire Dr Murphy because he doesn't
Inspire I fired him because he was
irrational unprofessional couldn't calm
down he couldn't control himself I mean
it's kind of fair feedback like I can't
even hate on the guy just as you have
the power to fire someone under your
supervision so do I you're going to fire
me to save d Murphy that's mad drastic
just be like yo we want to keep the guy
can you can you bring him back can we
mediate the situation you don't have to
fire him so did he get fired yeah sea
gets
rehired I feel like Shawn has trouble
falling asleep but here are
evidence-based ways of how to fall
asleep faster click here to check that
out and as always stay happy and
[Music]
healthy